SITUATION IN THE RACE.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Martha: THAT IS A GREAT
POINT, RICH.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
THAT'S WHERE I WANT TO START
WITH GLENN YOUNGKIN WHO JOINS US
NOW.
WE INVITED TERRY McAULIFFE AS
WELL.
WE'RE HERE IF HE WANTS TO HOP ON
AND TALK TO US AS WELL.
GOOD TO SEE YOU TODAY.
YOU HEARD RICH EDSON'S REPORT.
HE TALKS ABOUT THE EARLY VOTE,
WHICH WENT BACK TO SEPTEMBER
16th PEOPLE STARTED VOTING.
ABOUT A FIFTH OF THE VIRGINIA
ELECTORATE VOTED BEFORE YOU
STARTED TO TALK OFF IN THE
POLLS.
ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT THAT
COULD THROW THINGS IN TERRY
McAULIFFE'S DIRECTION TOMORROW
NIGHT?
>> NO, I FELT LIKE THE EARLY
VOTING WAS VERY MUCH
REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR STRENGTH.
IN FACT, TURNOUT FOR MY OPPONENT
WAS LIGHT AND SOFT.
WE HAD STRONG TURNOUT.
SO WE EXPECT TO DO WELL WITH THE
EARLY VOTING.
MOMENTUM ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
IS JUST HUGE.
WE'VE HAD A TEN-DAY BUSINESS
TOUR.
WE'VE BEEN ALL OVER THE
COMMONWEALTH.
WE'VE HAD STANDING ROOM ONLY.
SO EXCITED TO SEE VIRGINIIANS
COMING TOGETHER.
IT'S NO LONGER DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS.
THIS IS A PLATFORM FOR LOW
TAXES, SAFE NEIGHBORHOODS, A JOB
MARKET THAT IS GROWING.
>> Martha: WE'VE SEEN THE
CROWDS.
IT'S EVIDENT ON THE VIDEO WHEN
WE SEE THE CROWDS.
IT'S LIKE 51% OF EARLY VOTE IS
DEMOCRAT.
WHY DO YOU SAY YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
WOULD HAVE DONE WELL IN THAT
EARLY PORTION OF THE VOTE?
>> HISTORICALLY EARLY VOTING HAS
BEEN 75 TO 80% DEMOCRATS.
SO FOR US TO BE SO STRONG IN THE
EARLY VOTING REFLECTS THE FACT
THAT THERE'S NO ENTHUSIASM ON MY
OPPONENTS SIDE AND WE EXPECT TO
DO WELL TOMORROW.
VIRGINIIANS ARE COMING TOGETHER.
THAT'S WHY WE SEE SO MUCH
MOMENTUM TOMORROW.
THE EARLY VOTING IS GOING TO BE
SURPRISINGLY GOOD FOR US.
>> WE'LL SEE.
IT'S FASCINATING TO WATCH.
HERE'S WHAT TERRY McAULIFFE SAID
IN THE CLOSING HOURS HERE.
WATCH THIS.
>> YOU DON'T WANT A TRUMP
WANT-TO-BE.
HE'S BEEN ENDORSED BY TRUMP TEN
TIMES.
WE DON'T NEED THE DIVISION.
>> Martha: ARE YOU CLOSING YOUR
CAMPAIGN WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> WE'VE HAD HELP FROM
EVERYBODY.
THERE'S A TELECONFERENCE TONIGHT
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS HOSTING
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE HOLDING A
RALLY IN LOUDOUN COUNTY.
WE'VE BEEN GETTING HELP FROM
EVERYBODY.
WE HAD GOVERNORS FROM ALL OVER
THE UNITED STATES HOSTING
TELECALLS YESTERDAY TO GET THE
VOTE OUT FROM IDAHO AND ARIZONA
AND SOUTHOUT AND IOWA.
IT WAS FABULOUS TO SEE THE WHOLE
REPUBLICAN PARTY COME TOGETHER.
OH, BY THE WAY, TO SEE
INDEPENDENTS.
WE'RE WINNING THE INDEPENDENT
VOTE BY DOUBLE DIGITS.
WE HAVE DEMOCRATS WALKING A
CROSS THE AISLE.
THIS IS WHAT UNITY LOOKS LIKE
AND WHY WE'RE GOING TO WIN
TUESDAY.
WE HAVE TO GET THE VOTE OUT.
POLLS DON'T WIN ELECTIONS.
VOTE DOS.
GET OUT AND VOTE.
>> Martha: YOU'VE BEEN DOING
THAT IN THE SOUTHWEST PART OF
THE STATE TODAY.